salut à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition un peu spéciale d'europe et
d'eau dans cette émission je vous emmène
en finlande le pays est en récession et
cherche à se réinventer
comment trouver des leviers de
croissance quand on est un petit pays du
nord de l'europe
fort de cinq millions d'habitants nous
avons été à la rencontre de ce nouveau
modèle économique finlandais mais
d'abord invité exceptionnel pour
actualité exceptionnelle le pape
françois était ici à strasbourg pour
délivrer son message à l'europe face au
751 députés le pape françois a exhorté
l'union à respecter la dignité humaine
et à remettre l'homme au centre de la
construction européenne alors josé mario
bergoglio peut-il rendre son âme à
l'union c'est la question la semaine
posée par simon barbarie et c'est martin
schulz le président du parlement
européen que je reçois juste après
quatre heures chrono et de discours le
pape françois n'a pas abusé de
l'hospitalité alsacienne une visite
éclair est un véritable sermon fait au
vieux continent
c'est un peu partout on a l'impression
générale de fatigue de vieillissement
global note d'une europe et non pas
féconde et vega 26 ans que les instances
européennes n'avaient pas reçu la visite
d'un souverain pontife
et pour ce retour les représentants de
l'union en ont pris pour leur grade
l'europe est trop technocratique trop
éloignée des citoyens trop repliée sur
elle même
de tels propos de la part du
représentant du vatican
pas forcément l'état le plus ouvert du
monde cela pourrait faire sourire mais
ce serait oublier que françois est un
papa la parole libre qui veut ramener le
catholicisme à son message originel la
charité on peut pas tolérer aujourd'hui
que la méditerranée devienne un grand
cimetière d'enseignés qui arrivent
quotidiennement sur les côtés selon wang
min il ya les hommes et les femmes
tchétchènes qui ont besoin des cahiers
dead dignité de la personne humaine
protection de l'environnement ou encore
méfaits de la société de consommation
malgré son court voyage le premier
évêque de rome n'a pas été avare en
message alors le pape françois at il
rendu son âme à l'europe
bonsoir martin schulz bonsoir merci de
nous recevoir
vous avez reçu hier ici dans ces lieux
le pape françois à votre invitation
ça a été un petit peu un sermon de la
barre du bas françois à l'europe
il a fustigé une europe bureaucratique
loin des citoyens et parfois nuisible
ce qui a été repris d'ailleurs par nigel
farrage le leader des you keep ici au
parlement
est ce que vous pensez qu'il aura réussi
à insuffler cette âme que l'europe a
perdu tout d'abord le pape a fait un
discours très pro-européens il a fait un
appel aux européens de prendre l'idée de
l'europe cette coopération des nations
et des états au delà des frontières
ensemble pour se renforcer mutuellement
pour garanti la paix à l'intérieur à
travers de l'europe dans le monde comme
un cadeau prestigieux précieux mais l'a
dit cette idée à en contester mais vos
institutions vous vous êtes fatigué
alors redressé vous pour sauver cette
idée ça c'était un encouragement pour
tout le monde qu'il allait de vieille
europe
voilà c'est un encouragement pour les
gens qui pensent comme moi mais que
monsieur faraci l'interprète dans son
sens c'était peut-être parce qu'il n'a
pas compris ce que le pape a dit alors
est ce que jean luc mélenchon qui lui
aussi a dit aucune autorité religieuse
je cite n'a sa place dans une enceinte
parlementaire le pape est venu
monologuer nous administrer un prêche
nous n'avons pas eu le droit à la parole
c'est vous qui avait invité ce pape à
venir ici une première depuis 26 ans
qu'avez vous à lui répondre à jean luc
mélenchon
tout d'abord c'était mon prédécesseur
mes prédécesseurs qui avaient invité le
peuple et moi j'ai lors de
l'inauguration du pape françois répété
ces dernières invitations qui existait
déjà avant elle j'étais très heureux que
le pape l'a
finalement accepté de monsieur mélenchon
a son opinion mais là écrasante majorité
de son groupe parlementaire ici au
parlement a applaudi à plusieurs
reprises qu'ils ont même commencé
d'applaudir parce que je crois les
messages des pas bien c'était bien reçue
par la gauche unie peut être pas par
monsieur mélenchon qui par ailleurs il
n'est pas très longtemps membre du
parlement européen
ce moment où il était encore sénateur en
france
le dalaï lama a adressé le parlement
européen le moufti de damas a adressé le
parlement européen donc il se trompe
c'est pas le seul créneau ils se
trompent est là elle se trompe c'est
donc en gros jean luc mélenchon n'a pas
compris comment fonctionne le parlement
européen ont écouté jean luc mélenchon
c'est un collègue qui est toujours à la
recherche novembre un scandale qui suit
à l'autre pour ce faire intéressant bon
ça c'est aussi une stratégie dans la vie
politique avec laquelle il faut vivre
nous vivons très bien avec ça alors il
ya un autre scandale que le pape a
fustigé
monsieur le président c'est ces morts en
méditerranée il a parlé la méditerranée
comme d'un cimetière
on se souvient tous ici il ya un an au
mois de fin octobre dernier à lampedusa
plus de 300 morts toute l'europe s'en
émeut l'ancien président de la
commission européenne se rend sur place
et depuis rien alors est-ce que vous
allez laissez vous représentants de ces
institutions européennes faire de la
méditerranée un cimetière
non pas du tout moi je me suis rendu
lors de l'anniversaire
là bas j'ai rencontré certains nombre
des survivants
l'europe a besoin et moi j'appartiens à
ce qu'il propose depuis des années notre
politique de l'admiration nous avons
besoin la garantie de l'asile politique
nous avons besoin d'une protection
temporaire beaucoup plus approfondie
pour ceux qui ne veulent pas immigrés en
europe mais qui cherchent protection
pour guerre civile par exemple à cause
des guerres civiles ou des désastres
naturels et il y à un troisième élément
l'europe est un continent d'immigration
et nous avons besoin règlement européen
pour l'immigration
nourissier parlement européen avec une
large majorité nous sommes pour la
commission j'en suis sûr et une majorité
pour sa n'échoue pas à cause de l'erreur
pour échouer à cause de la volonté des
gouvernements nationaux pas de l'europe
donc le conseil
je crois pour les citoyens c'est plus
facile de dire le conseil personne peut
se l'imaginer qu'est ce que c'est le
conseil le conseil il ya le conseil
d'état chez vous en france mais là c'est
le conseil des gouvernements et des
chefs des tables qui est représenté au
sein des institutions est simple le
gouvernement de la france le
gouvernement de l'allemagne
le gouvernement du portugal j'en ai
marre de discuter toujours que l'europe
est responsable ici on peut identifier
le responsable
les responsables sont ceux qui mettent
l'intérêt national plus haut que
l'intérêt communautaire et l'intérêt
communautaire c'est de mettre fin à cet
événement à ces événements indigne pour
un continent basé sur valeurs qui se
passe dans la méditerranée donc appel
aux gouvernements nationaux de ré sport
de prendre leurs responsabilités
alors justement il ya un autre dossier
sur lesquelles les gouvernements vont
devoir prendre leur responsabilités sur
le plan de relance qui a été annoncé par
jean claude juncker de 315 milliards
est ce que vous y croyez finalement on
may 21 milliards sur la table mais
encore au titre de garantie pensant
qu'on va pouvoir lever plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros de
l'autre côté sur les marchés est-ce que
c'est pas utopique de croire qu'on va
pouvoir lever ces fonds non pas du tout
je suis d'accord avec le plan juncker je
soutiens avec conviction notre problème
c'est pas les 300 meilleurs pour tout le
monde il est clair que les trois cent
mille ans un point de départ
avec 300 lien on ne peut pas résoudre
tous nos problèmes
le grand problème de l'europe c'est que
l'argent qui est là qui est disponible
n'est pas attirée par l'économie réelle
les plans juncker c'est de donner des
garanties pour l'attirer les
investisseurs privés et ça c'est à mes
yeux peut-être pas un bâton magique mais
un pas dans la bonne direction
la bonne direction et de terminer avec
ce cette histoire qui nous avons raconté
des gens pendant des années qu'il faut
seulement assainir les budgets publics
réduire les dépenses et/ou chouchou
les investisseurs viennent investissent
nous réduisons les dépenses en assène
avec beaucoup des coupures des budgets
publics mais les investisseurs ne
viennent pas alors discipline budgétaire
et d'un côté oui c'est aussi une
question de solidarité entre générations
mais jamais vous assainir un budget
public sont croissance donc relance par
une combinaison des investissements
privés et publics à l'autre côté et avec
ça ils y ont qu à change la direction de
la politique européenne
alors il ya une action de la part d'un
ca de certains députés
deux sets initiaux notamment ceux de you
keep et du front national qui ont mis à
l'agenda ce lundi une motion de censure
contre jean-claude juncker concernant le
scandale du luxe l'x donc ces taxes
wings qui sont des accords secrets qui
permettait en fait de l'évasion fiscales
exonérations fiscales pour les grandes
entreprises
est-ce que c'est pas une action légitime
finalement de la part de ses députés
jour j on a besoin de 10 % des membres
légal du parlement pour présenter un
telle motion de censure ça veut dire
soixante seize députés et il ya 76
députés qui ont signé ça parmi eux
monsieur ferhat qui a selon mes
informations des comptes sur des îles de
la manche
il y à madame le pen qui prêtent
l'argent aux banques ruche alors des
experts qui en présentaient donc vous
réfutez la légitimité qu'ils auraient à
a pointé la responsabilité de jean
claude juncker dans ce dossier j'étais
un peu surpris sur quelques hypocrisie
juncker était 19 ans premier ministre du
luxembourg
il tenait pas caché pendant sept ans il
était toujours visible même en france et
le luxembourg avaient des règles très
spécial dans son système fiscal
c'était connu avant moi je ne suis pas
intéressé dans son passé de premier
ministre luxembourgeois
je suis intéressé que ça si sa
proposition de l'échangé automatique des
données d'informations automatique sur
les données des textes souligne que ces
règlements fiscale entre les états
membres est soutenu par 22 états membres
je veux savoir qui sont les six qui ne
soutiennent pas et qui sont les noms des
premiers ministres des ministres des
finances
c'est pourquoi ils sont contre c'est ce
qui m'intéresse parce que s'il ya les
vins bit qui le veulent
on peut immédiatement les mettra en
vigueur donc un autre cas où il ne faut
pas blâmer ni la commission ni le
parlement européen
mais il faut mettre les états membres
devant leurs responsabilités
alors je voudrais qu'on point de
quelques questions internationales
rapidement il était question d'un vote
de résolutions sur la palestine sur la
reconnaissance de la palestine
ce vote a été reporté pour quelles
raisons ça c'est une question
extrêmement délicate est controversé par
entre les groupes surtout à l'intérieur
des différents plus gros moi je suis un
allemand pour la république fédérale de
l'allemagne l'existence d'israël est une
raison d'être de notre état l'allemagne
mon ami frank walter steinmeier qui est
le mieux ses affaires étrangères à une
autre réputation sur les deux côtés très
reconnu gepi arabe est jeune et
palestiniens je ne voudrais aurait nommé
au côté israélien donc nous avons comme
stratégie en allemagne que sur la base
de la stratégie d oslo dans un processus
de la paix la reconnaissance mutuelle
peut passer ça c'est pas seulement nous
il ya aussi d'autres par exemple
parlement espagnol a voté dans cette
direction donc il y avait encore deux
des collègues qui avaient besoin un peu
plus d'approfondissement de ses analyses
et rob a voté en décembre
donc vous pouvez nous annoncer
aujourd'hui que cette résolution sera
votée en décembre
je suis sur ce tout d'abord rapporté en
décembre
je crois qu'on va voter hors de soi
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
nous avoir reçu leur cerveau nous on
continue direction la finlande ce pays
est entré en récession il ya déjà
quelques années et depuis la chute du
géant nokia essaye de se réinventer
reportage à tempérer et mc gee de paul
bouffard
les journées sont courtes
en ce mois de novembre au sud de la
finlande a tempéré le thermomètre
affiche -1° le pays des mille lacs un
modèle d'état providence scruté par
toute l'europe
mais la crise économique est aussi passé
par la population vieillissante panne de
champions industriels
le pays est en récession depuis 2012
mais takuo comment ça va comme-ci
comme-ça visite matinale pour le docteur
holly paulo ce médecin du sommeil
exercice' dans le privé à la clinique
onesta mais aussi à l'hôpital public
non loin de là alors pour lui le constat
est clair le système de santé finlandais
va mal symptôme numéro un
les consultations augmente à la clinique
privée les patients ont fui lé manque de
moyens à l'hôpital
en 2013 le gouvernement lance un plan de
réduction des dépenses publiques de plus
de 9 milliards d'euros c'est à l'hôpital
public vous avez deux solutions pour
vous soigner
soit vous allez aux urgences directement
soit vous attendez longtemps pour avoir
en rendez vous environ trois mois à
helsinki
l'ambiance est plutôt rock costumes bien
taillés à l'aise sur scène ce n'est pas
le dernier chanteur fois pas la mode non
c'est alexander stubb
le premier ministre finlandais je rêvais
d'y croire ou travailler dur et réussir
il est là devant des centaines
d'entrepreneurs tous réunis pour ce
lunch 2014
rendez vous européen des créateurs de
start-up objectif donner un nouvel élan
à l'économie finlandaise en 2009 un des
piliers de cette économie le géant de la
téléphonie nokia rate le coche de la
révolution smartphones l'ancien leader
mondial est racheté par microsoft
aujourd'hui le premier ministre boost
l'émergence de dizaine de start up
recyclant les ingénieurs licenciés
il faut être un peu libérale
je sais que c'est pas très populaire en
france mais je crois que avec l'économie
il faut toujours rester libéral pour
nokia qui était énorme
on a eu beaucoup d ingénieurs et
maintenant on a des ingénieurs un peu en
arrière qui crée beaucoup de sociétés
comme google sur ses parcelles
angry birds clash of khan des jeux sur
smartphones qui font fureur dans le
monde
une fierté nationale pour ce petit pays
de cinq millions d'habitants
il ya aussi très lab plus vite plus vite
plus vite aller le résultat va tomber
une start up qui fabrique un petit
marque tag un jeton intelligent sans fil
pour calculer les mouvements il y as
terreau 15 ans chez nokia avec trois
autres anciens de la firme ils ont
regroupé leurs talents pour rebondir
nous sommes les nouveaux moteurs de
l'économie nous pouvons produire de
nouvelles choses de nouveaux business
une nouvelle manière de travailler
pendant des décennies l'économie du pays
a reposé sur deux champions
aujourd'hui à terre la téléphonie de
nokia et l'industrie du bois
noka c'était 7 milliards d'euros
d'exportations en 2007
aujourd'hui plus qu'un milliard par an
pour la journaliste pas évident isotta
luce la finlande met du temps à se
réinventer
nous avons perdu notre triple a en
octobre dernier et ça a été un gros choc
pour le pays parce que nous pensions
être les meilleurs on pensait que notre
économie était la meilleure cote et la
finlande
70 % de son territoire n'est que forêt
la plus grande industrie de pâte à
papier au monde et pourtant les géants
du secteur sont forcés de réduire la
voilure upm entreprise leader mondial
tente le tout pour le tout rebondir avec
les bioénergies et même un prototype
venus d'ailleurs ça c'est peut-être la
solution pour plein de choses
ce combo montré chez upm c'est qu'une
voiture peut être fabriqué entièrement
en bois une voiture en bois bio fort de
son petit nom un nouvel étendard pour la
firme dans l'économie finlandaise on
peut aussi bien combiner les nouvelles
industries comme les jeux vidéo avec
l'innovation des bioénergies
retour chez très lab au coeur de la
start up
le laboratoire de terreau quand il s'est
fait licencié de chez noka avec ses ex
collègues il a bénéficié du nokia bridge
un programme de reconversion pour aider
les salariés
25000 euros pour que ces cerveaux créer
leur entreprise
un incubateur qui va même plus loin
nokia a permis à certains de partir avec
leur brevet pour qu'ils développent
leurs produits seuls notre expérience
chez nokia est vraiment la clé
maintenant sans ça on n'aurait pas eu
ces atouts technologiques à qui l'accès
à la technologie sans ça on n'aurait pas
eu les process dont on avait besoin pour
créer notre produit reconversion réussie
à slush très lab a été élu comme l'une
des meilleures startups de finlande et
l'aventuré ne fait que commencer
treize personnes travaillent aujourd'hui
sur le produit terreau nos fonds fille
il compte bien doubler ce nombre d'ici
l'année prochaine
et voici pour son reportage donc en
finlande par paul bouffard le modèle
finlandais peut-il s'exporter c'est la
question que je vais poser à yannick
jadot bonjour vous êtes ici vice
président de la commission du commerce
international et membre du groupe des
verts quand vous voyez un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé en finlande donc
récession en 2012 depuis 2012 politique
de rigueur l'état providence on à sabrer
dans les dépenses de santé d'éducation
et finalement on essaye de se réinventer
est ce que cette politique de rigueur ou
d'austérité n'a pas finalement du bon
est-ce que ça permet pas de se relancer
un petit peu je crois pas qu'il soit
nécessaire de sacrifier l'hôpital en
finlande pour aider les startups et pour
aider la transition énergétique
ce qu'on essaye de développer à
l'échelle européenne on sait les
secteurs qui aujourd'hui emploi qui
génère de l'activité
c'est la transition énergétique les
économies d'énergie l'efficacité et les
énergies renouvelables
c'est d'ailleurs le secteur de la santé
c'est même la commission européenne qui
le disaient que c'est un secteur où sur
lequel il faut énormément investir
notamment en termes de formation
personnelle les personnels de santé en
europe sont vieillissants la population
est vieillissante on a besoin de
nouveaux services
et puis c'est le secteur du numérique
donc il faut aider ces secteurs là se
développer il faut leur créer l'espace
mais il faut aussi s'assurer qu'on
arrive à passer de l'ancienne économie
les énergies fossiles des économies très
ou des secteurs d'économies très près de
quatre heures on voit là le secteur de
la forêt en finlande qui étaient quittes
qui est en train de détruire la dernière
forêt primaire finlandaise en europe
donc il faut aider aussi à cette
transition et la question de la
formation des salariés
la question de la formation des jeunes
sera au coeur doit être au coeur d'une
politique européenne sinon sortira pas
du chômage des jeunes on sortira pas du
chômage de masse et on n'arrivera pas à
se réorienter sur les secteurs modernes
comme vous avez alexander stubb donc qui
est le premier ministre finlandais qui
vous interpellent en disant il faut
libéraliser après tout on n'aime pas ce
mot là en france c'est un gros mot en
soyons clairs est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec lui ou comme vous parlais
justement de ces startups qu'il faut
créer de cette économie numérique qu'il
faut libérer et de cette croissance
peut-être qu'il faut retrouver via les
énergies renouvelables et c est ce qui
n'a pas raison finalement si c'est pour
libérer les
hergies je suis à 100% d'accord on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui souvent dans
l'économie les énergies vitales à cent
pas dans les vieux secteur à son dans
ces secteurs très dynamique donc libérer
ces secteurs là je suis d'accord mais ce
qu'on voit malheureusement le plus
souvent en europe c'est qu'on continue à
soutenir les vieux secteur ont continué
à soutenir
on continue à subventionner le charme on
continue à subventionner les énergies
fossiles
il ya un autre problème en fait qui est
posée au travers de toute cette
politique de relance de la croissance
et j'aimerais qu'on écoute en fait le
l'intervenant qui était dans le
reportage est là une question directe à
vous poser
how do you monument est et comment
pourriez-vous réduire les démarches
administratives et la paperasserie
imposées par l'union européenne
alors même le pape en a parlé l'union
européenne a ce côté un petit peu
nuisibles de créer des règles là où il
n'en faut pas comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait un petit peut réduire toute
cette paperasse et permettre justement
de relancer cette économie par ce biais
souvent sur le papier les fonds
européens sont souvent les meilleurs
fonds d aide que ce soit aux
associations aux entreprises ou aux
collectivités
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut généralement
1 2 ans voire trois ans pour obtenir
l'argent au bout d'un moment avec des
dossiers administratifs qui sont
totalement hallucinant alors il faut
simplifier ça tout le monde le sait à
l'échelle européenne
c'est un engagement du président juncker
avec la nouvelle commission mais il faut
savoir que si l'argent européen est
aussi difficile à obtenir
c'est aussi parce que les états membres
impose des contraintes permanentes
alors justement jean claude juncker a
présenté son plan de relance de 300
milliards
est-ce que ça va être simplifié ou pas
nous le verrons bien dans les faits
sachant que le déficit d'investissements
a été de 540 milliards sur les deux
dernières années est ce que il va assez
loin
il a de l'ambition il veut mettre sur le
social sur la transition énergétique
c'est une bonne chose il veut faire en
sorte que chaque projet qui sera financé
par ce plan soit contrôlé
démocratiquement que syriens puissent
savoir quels sont les investissements
qui sont faits le problème c'est que il
n'a pas d'argent il met pas d'argent sur
la table il dit serait d'intermédiaire
il fait un milliard mais c'est des gars
en garantie c'est de l'argent qui existe
déjà dans le budget européen et ça va
attirer pour chaque euro public européen
15 euros d'argent privé la réalité
infirme ce type d'effet de levier
multiplicateur on est malheureusement
potentiellement en train de confirmer
l'idée qu'on va socialiser les pertes
donc c'est l'argent public qui assurera
les risques et c'est l'argent privé qui
tirera les bénéfices
il faut surtout que cet argent soit
orientée totalement différemment
la bce a fourni 1000 milliards aux
banques on compte y est essentiellement
avec l'argent public européen à financer
des banques à financer des
investissements financiers et l'économie
elle est à aller encore vers des projets
comme le lyon turin ou potentiellement
notre dame des landes tout ça qui sont
des projets qui ne servent pas les
citoyens européens
alors justement vous évoquez la capacité
en fait via la transition énergétique à
créer de l'emploi et de la relance
vous êtes le coordinateur pour le groupe
des verts pour la conférence de l'ue
mais la conférence sur le climat qui va
se tenir en décembre prochain
est ce que vous y croyez encore
finalement assez conférence qui
n'aboutissent jamais à rien il faut y
croire
on n'a pas le choix tous les rapports
scientifiques se succèdent et nous
disent que si nous n'agissons pas ce
sera un crime contre l'humanité parce
que c'est accepter qui va y avoir des
millions de morts descendent des
dizaines de millions de déplacés
climatiques
on va avoir des catastrophes permanente
dans tous les pays
du point de vue du climat les
inondations les canicules aujourd'hui la
responsabilité des dirigeants
ce n'est plus de nous montrer la voie
c'est de libérer les îles par exemple de
penser que sans morizet quand cela si
les états unis signent un accord de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre vous
êtes confiant où vous dites que c'est
encore pas assez s'est passé c'est un
bon signal que les états unis la chine
fasse cette annonce là que l'europe
fasse une annonce quelques semaines
avant sur ses objectifs climatiques
c'est bien ça montre que le sujet sur la
table le problème c'est que les
objectifs tels qu'ils sont annoncées
aujourd'hui ne sont pas à la hauteur du
défi climatique
on sait qu'il faut pas dépasser 2 degrés
sinon exactement sinon ce sera ce que
dit la banque mondiale un cataclysme
donc ce qu'on doit démontrer à la
société et à nos dirigeants dans les
mois qui viennent avant l'imam et
surtout avant la grande conférence
départ de paris c'est que si on lutte
contre les dérèglements climatiques
ça n'est pas une contrainte on vivra
mieux en gros dans une société qui lui
confère maintenant plan de relance
possible
c'est le meilleur plan de relance
possible et c'est la meilleure façon de
se rapproprier les questions politiques
de remettre de la démocratie dans nos
institutions à l'arrêt dans nos vies
justement pour parler démocratie
institution vient d'apprendre que
l'union européenne ouvre officiellement
une procédure d'infraction contre la
france sur la question de sivens qu'est
ce que vous avez à répondre à ça
c'est une évidence il ya déjà une
procédure d'infraction sur notre dame
des landes
vous savez que la cour des comptes
critique énormément le projet lyon turin
il ya toute une série de projets en
france qui servent plus à quelques égos
d'élus locaux qui servent plus à
quelques intérêts privés qui ne servent
pas les citoyens
c'est un gaspillage d'argent public
c'est une destruction de notre
environnement
c'est ce que dit la commission
européenne en tout cas c'est ce sur quoi
elle attend des réponses beaucoup plus
claire du gouvernement
je savais que c'est une zone humide et
dont il va falloir qu'il va falloir avec
tous ces blocages ces mobilisations et
on a vu le drame à 6,20 il va falloir
que le gouvernement français le
président de la république remette à
plat tous ces projets tous ceux qui
luttent à notre dame des landes à civens
ailleurs il lutte pas pour leurs
intérêts privés
ils luttent pour qu'on vive mieux
écouter on s'arrêtera sur ces mots merci
beaucoup yannick j'allais avoir été
parmi nous nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine ciao
bon